I get asked this one question a bunch
which is what inspires you to create
stuff notice this has been a weird and
hard question for me to answer because I
don't really know what people mean by
inspire is inspiration this mystical
magical force in the universe that hits
you and provokes you to want to make
something new I don't really know what
inspiration means for most people which
is why I don't ever really answer this
question head-on but in the name of
trying to answer this question I've been
thinking a lot about it
let me start off by telling you what I
think inspiration doesn't mean I don't
think inspiration is that burst of
enthusiasm for something or that
fleeting feeling of excitement when you
hear a motivational speech or you read a
self-help book in the course of a 10
minute video or a short book you can
feel those feelings of excitement and
motivation but I don't really see that
as inspiration inspiration is kind of
the opposite in the sense that it is
quieter it's not a burst of excitement
or enthusiasm for me it's a quieter
thing that you have to wrestle with and
you have to discern it and you have to
act on it the best kind of inspiration
lets me see the thing that
I want to make it doesn't tell me how to
make it but it allows me to see
something that doesn't exist and then
start the long process of building it so
by this definition of inspiration which
is my own version probably different
than yours but by this definition I can
actually answer this question of what
inspires me I can think of one thing
that fuels this desire to visualize
something that doesn't exist and then
plot the course to make it a reality and
that thing that inspires me is music
[Music]
okay wait hold on a second if if you
think that I'm going to spend the rest
of this video just talking in kind of
fluffy vague language about what
inspires me that's not the case for the
rest of the video I want to actually
give you some concrete helpful tips on
how inspiration works for me and
particularly how I use music to help
frame out and tell stories I'm not
innocent when it comes to fluffy
motivational stuff but this video will
not be that from now on so with that
let's get back to it I'm going to play
an a-flat major seven which is one of my
favorite chords and I'll tell you a
quick story in 2013 is and I had just
bought our first like semi-professional
camera
and I went on a trip to Peru I was just
getting into like filming travels and
editing it together so that's what I did
when I was in Peru with my new nice
camera while I was driving up into the
mountains my Pandora radio playlist
served me up this song
[Laughter]
[Music]
this immediately sparked something for
me this song while I was driving really
made me feel things and it's the first
time that I can remember feeling
inspired to make something based on a
piece of music so I went back and I made
this video that included a whole scene
of me driving through the mountains with
this music this song is frankly like too
dramatic it's like a little bit too
emotional for what I was doing which is
just like traveling by myself in Peru it
doesn't really match the tone of the
little story I'm telling here the song
really should be more something like
this
[Music]
I'm gonna talk more about tone matching
and how I think about that
when it comes to using music to tell
stories but for now let's use this
little Peru example to talk about my
first not fluffy concrete tip when it
comes to inspiration and music I was a
kid learning to tell stories but while
this song wasn't maybe the best choice
to set the tone and maybe it wasn't the
most appropriate the thing that was good
about this experience is that I at least
felt inspiration and then I acted on it
I think it's really easy to feel
inspired by something and feel a desire
to make something like that or to
integrate a song or something into your
video and then immediately put up
blockades to that by saying oh this
probably is good enough oh I probably
shouldn't do this because it's not cool
enough that's the best way to squash
inspiration my suggestion my tip here is
that if you feel any sort of inspiration
you feel a desire to make something
based on something you've seen or heard
follow it nurture it try to see it
through this was the first time I ever
acted on it and yeah it wasn't perfect
or great or whatever but it was the
beginning of a long journey a vacuum an
inspiration that would eventually become
better and better with time
[Music]
okay so now for tip number two to me
music is like a superpower you have this
ability to make your viewer feel or
think in a certain way for just a minute
in the name of telling a story or
communicating an idea that's really
powerful perhaps the biggest mistake and
sometimes the most egregious offence
when it comes to using music and telling
stories is exactly what you saw with my
Peru video abusing this music that is
meant to kind of pull the heartstrings
and make you feel something when the
story or the scene in the video really
doesn't deserve it to me cheapens your
video and it takes away your ability to
use that heart stirring tugging
emotional music in a place that actually
deserves it to actually create an
emotional investment using music I call
this tone matching or earning the
feelings of your viewer don't unfairly
use emotional music when the story
doesn't warrant it it's cheap it's
trashy I've done it a million times it's
not a good look okay so this third tip
is gonna really help with what I just
talked about with tone matching and
earning feelings and stuff like that in
my mind I see almost all music as
falling into two big buckets there is
feeling music which is what we just
talked about feeling emotional it pulls
at your heartstrings feeling music and
then on the other side there is thinking
music which is a very different vibe of
music this allows the viewer to be more
focused on what you're saying and to
engage more of their brain instead of
like they're feeling parts if you're
sharing information or you're sharing
context or stuff that isn't really kind
of emotional or personal this is the
type of music that you want to use okay
I'm talking a lot of abstract terms
thinking feeling I want to dive in and
show you what this actually looks like
when I'm looking for music I actually
reached out to music bed when I was
writing this video and told them that I
was making a video about
music and inspiration and that I was
going to be doing a demo on their site
ask them if they wanted to sponsor it
and they said yes so music read sponsors
this video I in by no means making this
video because of music bed I would have
made it anyway
but thank you music vet for sponsoring
this video I will talk about that later
at the end of the video for now I want
to show you this demo using music bed
and feel like I had to tell you that
music that sponsored this video you can
see that just in the genres tab here
there are way more genres and types of
music than just thinking and feeling I
want to be clear that I'm not saying
that those are the only two types of
music that I use in my videos I'm saying
that all of this music usually falls
within one or the other of those buckets
so let's talk feeling first I often find
that if I hit things like ambient I'm
gonna get a lot of feeling music if you
use this at the beginning of your video
and you're not talking about like an
emotional thing
you're off base you should use this
music once you've earned some sort of
emotional investment or if you're
talking about something that's emotional
and personal and that warrants this
really beautiful sense of feeling
[Music]
okay so ambient you'll often find some
feeling pieces in the ambient category
cinematic is another one we often find
more somber contemplative feeling type
music
you're not gonna be doing an explainer
over this this is uplifting this is
emotional this is the climax of a big
journey that is now happening or a
beautiful thing like a wedding uplifting
acoustic like obviously that's gonna be
feeling music uplifting it's an
emotional word
[Music]
coming home after five years away we're
feeling something you're gonna use this
earn it okay so what about for thinking
pieces I've talked a lot about like
emotional feeling pieces I think you
know it when you hear it now but what
about thinking pieces what does that
sound like abstract beats let's see what
abstract beats anything with beats is
often thinking there's not going to be
deep emotional stuff when the focus of
the music is as a beach sometimes there
is but often that's a great signal that
we're talking about more of a thinking
piece yeah this is a high energy
thinking piece this is like I'm moving
along we're going on an adventure we're
talking about stuff this is cooler it's
less emotional it's a little bit more
emotionally neutral this is sweet
yep I'm definitely downloading this one
for future use thank you let's see
what's in travel thinking piece the
other thing you can do instead of just
looking at playlists is you can really
hone in by deciding exactly what kind of
attributes or adjectives you want to use
so there's on Rah's you could say I'm
looking for like electronic music and
the mood I want it to be chill and I
want it to be happy okay let's say I'm
looking for a thinking piece maybe chill
and happy might give me a think e-type
piece you may give me a little to
feeling with that happy in there we'll
see
I've used this one for explainer II yeah
great thinking piece just not not too
emotional my pulling anyone's
heartstrings too much with this yeah
this is a good one electric chill happy
good okay let's do one more let's try to
get let's say okay I've got a video I
have created this big emotional arc and
I want there to be a climax where at the
end of this long journey I finally make
it to this destination that I have hyped
the viewer up in the course of my story
let's find a feeling piece that will now
fit within that because you've earned
the right to now use this emotional
music to communicate exactly what you're
feeling so I want to just stay in mood
and say uplifting peaceful love
contemplative maybe
yeah this is like really feeling stuff
beautiful drone shot on sunrises we're
finally making it to the final peak here
comes a swell you can see it in the
waveforms what its gonna be triumphant
yeah it resolves a little bit yeah I
like this you get the point you thinking
versus feeling I want to make it clear
not every song is like one or the other
it's often some spectrum but when I'm
thinking of music I'm often thinking of
does it fall more into one or the other
category and what is the tone and trying
to set am I just talking about
information and kind of showing us
getting from one place to the other
that's more of a thinking these am I
talking about personal things or having
an emotional kind of climax that's
happening in the middle of the story
that's gonna be more of a feeling
the fourth concrete tip and the thing
that maybe is now the most important tip
if you're following along with these
different concepts of thinking and
feeling and telling matching and stuff
like that
when I am telling a story that has kind
of an ebb and flow at ten minute video
or you know on Porter's episode or a
vlog or whatever it is I want to make
sure that my story goes back and forth
between thinking scenes and feeling
scenes so I don't know look at the most
recent video I did on Amsterdam okay so
I start off with this thinking piece
information over here celo thinking
piece look at this oh and you see that
so this this is more of just a
storytelling principle generally on how
I structure my stories I want there to
be a piece where there's a lot of
information and just as the viewers
brain is getting tired of like tons of
explainer information use choice tears
and you change the tone to something
more emotional or feeling based how do I
do that I'm in this explainer part where
I'm explaining this section about how
they took this they built a wall and
they built all these islands on the wall
and this and that and then let's take a
breather and feel for a little bit
kind of just like absorb this big thing
if you watch one of my videos you will
notice that I go back and forth between
thinking and feeling it's not like one
for one for one for one it's not like
some mathematical formula I try to make
it a journey back and forth between the
more cerebral thinking pieces and the
more emotional personal pieces they
don't have to always be like sappy
emotional but are just a little bit less
cerebral and a little bit more sensory
or feelings based so I really hope it
made sense and I hope you can apply some
of these principles to whatever you're
doing if you've stuck around this long
into the video you clearly are
interested in some aspect of this so I'm
curious to hear what clicked with you
and what didn't as I said earlier this
video is sponsored by music bed loop
music bed into this idea because it
seemed like a good fit and because of
that they want to give all of you who
are watching this a 30-day trial to have
unlimited access to their giant library
of wonderful music as you saw you can
use these playlists and these attributes
to really sort through and find the
music that you're looking for to tell
your story cool thing about music bed is
that it's not royalty free meaning if
you use an artist music they will get
paid which is kind of cool but for you
as the Creator you can just download
unlimited songs for the monthly
subscription and use them and monetize
them even and get paid yourself if
you're a YouTube creator or if you're
just making videos for fun it's also
just a really cheap way to get good
music so there's a link in the
description that you can click on and
get a month for free and test it out and
see if it works if you like it see if
you're into it thank you music but for
sponsoring this video and thank you for
watching I will see you next time
[Music]